[Musique]
écrire un livre
la bonne blague j'ai très mal commencé
ma relation à l'écrit j'ai un souvenir
douloureux d'une dictée dans laquelle il
y avait le mot robinet ne sachant trop
comment s'écrivait la terminaison jeu
les conjuguer est écrit as you and i t
il y en avait plusieurs
c'est du pluriel mais une dictée c'est
facile on vous donne le texte une
rédaction c'est beaucoup plus dur
j'ai un autre souvenir très douloureux
avec une rédaction que j'avais mais
magnifiquement commencé j'avais dressé
le paysage un chemin qui s'enfonçait
dans la forêt le soleil au bout le thème
de la rédaction c'est l ennui l'ennui
c'est que j'ai plongé dans l'ennui
direct ma rédaction était terminée donc
vous comprenez que l'écrit c'est pas mon
truc
et pour compléter ce tableau
j'ai intégré une école d'ingénieurs en
agroalimentaire à montpellier alors
montpellier vous descendez sur palavas
les flots à droite vous avez villeneuve
les maguelone et le lac des aresquiers
j'ai donc essentiellement travaillé
l'option planche à voile qui était pas
dans le cursus je me suis fait virer
alors 30 ans après avoir l'ambition
d'écrire un livre de quelques centaines
de pages
c'était pas gagné j'ai commencé
ma jeunesse elle a été tiraillé entre
mon combo zoom x celui de ma mère
scientifique au cnrs et mon chromosome y
celui de mon père commercial et
entrepreneurs alors j'ai vaguement
résolu mon dilemme
j'ai fait que des études scientifiques
et je n'ai fait qu'une activité
professionnelle de commercial et
entrepreneurs et j'ai commencé en 91
alors pour les jeunes dans la salle 91
c'est zéro internet c'est zéro réseaux
sociaux les téléphones portables c'est
des grosses cabines téléphoniques sur la
route toujours là quand on en a pas
besoin jamais là quand on en a besoin et
des ordinateurs portables sur lesquels
on travaillait c'était des cahiers
clairefontaine avec des stylos bic
j'ai commencé donc commercial le
meilleur métier du monde
c'est un métier de passion des changes
de relations humaines de conviction un
métier dur aussi où parfois on se frite
parce que une vente ne peut avoir lieu
que s'il ya un achat en face mais j'ai
tendance à dire que le meilleur endroit
du monde c'est chez le client ou avec
mes interlocuteurs on essaye de trouver
les solutions à leurs problèmes fin 90
fin des années 90 plus tôt et début des
années 2000
espace 2 choses pour moi dont une qui
vous impact frontalement mais si vous me
le permettez je vais commencer par la
mienne je passe un entretien avec un
recruteur qui me posent la question
introspective relou pour un candidat
pourquoi vous êtes commercial monsieur
donc moi du tac au tac vous prépare
toujours nos réponses à vos questions un
peu relou commercial pour les relations
humaines et la lui du tac au tac non par
contre il laisse bien flipper un peu
chacun sa réponse et hindi dans monsieur
vous fait ça parce que vous voulez être
aimé alors j'ai pas fais des années de
psychanalyse mais je crois que imams une
grande claque et
je pense qu'il a raison la deuxième
chose qui se passe et c'est celle qui
vous touche énormément aujourd'hui c'est
que il ya le train ou les trains de
l'internet qui sont arrivés alors mon
côté un peu geek m'a fait détecter cette
nouvelle technologie et j'ai senti que
ça allait changer mon job au métier de
commercial mon activité est certainement
le monde entier et je me suis même mis à
écrire j'ai ouvert un blog et j'ai écrit
alors pas sur les robinets
même si j'ai appris à écrire
correctement mais sur les sujets que je
traitais l'e-mail marketing les
conversations digital peas sont venus se
greffer les réseaux sociaux internet est
devenu une passion est devenue mon job
et il ya un réseau social qui a paru en
2006 linkedin et c'est devenu mon
nouveau terrain de jeu sur ce réseau je
me suis retrouvé en fait avec un double
numérique avec 1 une extension de mon
moi professionnels et on sent on s'est
créé une carte d'identité digital
professionnel et ça m'a permis de faire
des rencontres humaines fabuleuses
j'ai rencontré mes deux associés dans
deux sociétés différentes dont une dans
laquelle je suis encore j'ai rencontré
des gens qui avaient des choses
passionnantes à dire et je les ai
rencontrés pour les interviewer en vidéo
parce qu'à l'époque je développer un
média internet
j'ai aussi fait du business j'ai signé
des baux contrat parce que linkedin gh
c'est aussi un réseau social propos le
business et puis j'ai pu détecter des
personnes qui avaient un usage de ce
réseau linkedin et j'ai pu les invités à
venir faire des très beaux témoignages
dans mon livre mais ce réseau il est
utile à tout le monde
il va être utile à l'étudiant qui va
commencer à construire son réseau qui va
se rentrer dans la vie active et qui va
peut-être même trouvé son futur stage ou
sans alternance
il va être utile aux chômeurs qui a
besoin de rester en contact en
conversation avec son écosystème
et qui a besoin de trouver un job voire
de créer son job
j'ai vécu cette période et je me suis
servi ce réseau dans ma période de
chômage
il est utile à l'entrepreneur qui va
développer sa société il va être utile
aux managers qui va pouvoir faire monter
en compétences toute son équipe il va
être utile aux dirigeants voire aux
membres du codir pour développer leur
présence digitale et surtout avoir un
rôle d'exemplarité pour que toute la
société viennent utiliser ces nouveaux
outils utiles pour faire des relations
professionnelles dans un cadre business
la question c'est qu'est ce que votre
profil va dire aux personnes qui vont
venir le voir parce qu'effectivement le
profil il est accessible 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
quand moi je dors ibos pour moi enfin
mon profil bosse pour moi quand les gens
viennent le voir vous êtes là en train
d'assister à ce tedx mais pour tous ceux
pour un profil ibos pour vous la
question c'est ce qu'ils bossent en bien
ou en mal
dire que votre photo votre accroche
votre résumé la partie un petit peu
théorique statique parle à l'individu à
l'interlocuteur qui vient visiter votre
profil mais c'est pas la partie la plus
importante la plus importante c'est la
capacité que vous avez à être en
conversation avec vos relations
professionnelles
d'un point de vue humain des prospects
des clients des partenaires des
prestataires des collaborateurs mais
même vous concurrents c'est un réseau
est essentielle aujourd'hui pour
développer son business et des relations
professionnelles
j'ai l'intimé conviction que la plupart
d'entre vous passez à côté de cette
opportunité magnifique parce que vous
comprenez pas à vous maîtrisez pas vous
n'avez pas un aperçu de ce que cet outil
permet de faire en termes de relations
professionnelles
alors un jour puisque j'arrivais à bien
écrire robinet j'ai dit je vais écrire
un livre pour redonner à tout le monde
ce que j'ai pu apprendre
me comprendre tous les bénéfices que ce
réseau m'a apporté et puisque je parle
de relations humaines
eh ben c'est ce réseau qui m'a permis de
croiser la route d'un éditeur qui a
accepté de relever mon challenge
d'écrire un livre
challenge ambitieux je vais pas parler
d'eux mais robin mes problèmes de
robinets et puis comme c'est aussi des
histoires de relations humaines
en fait si je suis ici ce soir pour
pouvoir partager mon histoire c'est
parce que un responsable de
l'organisation du tedx a pris contact
avec moi sur lingling pour me proposer
de venir partager avec vous alors
lending a changé ma vie changer votre
vie avec lui merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]